네 지금 시각은 5시 26분 있니다
오늘 영상은 제 브이로그를 찍어
보려고 하는데 저는 보통 한 5시 반
6시 정도에 나옵니다 그래서 일어나는
시간은 어 보통 평균적으로 한 4시
반이나 5시 정도 일어나고요 회사
도착하면 한 6시 반이나 한 7시
정도에네 도착해 가지고 업무를
시작합니다 그래서 저는 좀 일찍
업무를 시작하고 밤에는 좀 일찍
잡니다 제가 술을 안 먹기 때문에
웬만하면 한 9시나 10시 정도에
자려고 하고 대신 아침에 굉장히 좀
빨리 일어납니다 그리고 업무를 제가
좀 아침에 많이 보는 편인데 그 대신
퇴근은 웬만하면 좀 6시 전에 하려고
합니다 그리고 퇴근하고 나서 좀
가족들이랑 시간을 좀 많이 보내려고
하고 있고요 지금 아들 둘이 있는데
아들이 좀 한창 지금 이쁠 때여서 좀
웬만하면 일찍 가서 조금이라도 조금
놀아주려고 하고 있 있습니다 오늘은
좀 제 일상을 좀 영상으로 담으려고
하는데 기대하셔도 좋을 것 같습니다
그러면 지금 운전해서 회사로 이동해
보도록
하겠습니다네 지금 회사에 도착을
했습니다 지금 밖은 되게 어둡고 어
굉장히 지금 좀 조용한 그런
상태입니다 좀 이런 걸 되게 좋아해요
좀 되게 조용하고 저만에 뭔가 생각할
수 있는 시간을 갖는게 굉장히 좀
저는 소중한 거 같고 보통은이
시간대에 앞으로 좀 뭘 해야 될지 좀
좀 많이 생각하는 편입니다 보통 한
6시나 6시 반 정도에 업무를 시작을
하고 제가 오늘은 필라테스를 받진
않은데 보통 아침 7시에 필라테스도
좀 하거든요 그래서 주에 한 1 2회
정도 필라테스도 하고 있습니다 오늘은
받는 날은 아니어서 업무를 보다가
이따가 8시 반에 또 회의가 있거든요
회의 또 준비도 하고 하겠습니다
아침에 나와서 보통 생각이나 아니면
이제 뭐 오늘 할 일 같은 거 그런
거 좀 정리도 하고 그다음에
중간중간에 뭐 TV 좀 보면서 최근에
뭐 이런 이슈들이 많더라고요네 그래서
좀 세계 돌아가는 거라든지 앞으로
어떻게 될 건지 뭐 그런 것도 좀
찾아서 보고 있습니다 아침이라서 목이
좀
잠기네요 그래서 보통은 캘린더를 보고
오늘 뭐 할지 일정을 좀 체크하고
오늘은 뭐 일정이 괜찮네요 오늘 뭐
해야 될 업무들을 좀 이렇게 생각해서
좀 정리해
봅니다네 그래서 좀 약간 회의 준비를
좀 했다가 8시 반에 어 또 다시
촬영을 하도록 하겠습니다 저 어느
정도 저거 잡아줘서 아 비상 터 건
공상 말씀드리고 하겠습니다 어제 선동
8 28나 공정률 한 48% 정도
되고 있고요 지금 공사가 지금 전체
한 40% 정도 된 경우 지금 저희
설개 거는 3 3-1 저희 그 현수아
그거 조금 이렇게 바꾸는 건 어떠세요
저희 거 예 어 뭐 예 그거 한번 좀
크게 바꾸면 될 거 같아요 글씨 좀
많이 나가지고 좀 잘 안 보이는 거
같아음 아니면 그냥 같은 거를 써도
되지 않 같은 거 해도 돼요 만들고
있거든요 내부에서 이게 좋을까 저게
좋을까 그리고 저기 그 블로그 포스팅
봤는데 많이 약하죠
죄송합니다
청남동 여기는 내용만지 정리해서 그
사람 뽑는 거보다 그게 비용이 들어갈
것 같아 어 8시 반에 회의를 좀
마치고 지금 10시에 또 미팅하는
곳으로 또 이동해 봐야 될 것 같아요
건설업이 좀 되게 시장이 되게 좀 안
좋은데 어 그래도 다행히 bsn
건설이 수주도 괜찮게 했고 그리고
공자도 뭐 차질없이 잘 진행하고
있어서 되게 다행인 거 같습니다 뭐
요즘에는 항상
내년은 어떻게 할까 좀 고민을 많이
하는 거 같아요 그래서 bsn 건설도
내년에 좀 어떻게 운영할지 뭐 그런
것들을 주로 얘기를 했습니다 그래서
제가 이번에 좀 많이 느낀 거는
사업이라는게 좀 이렇게 다각화를 좀
해야 되는 거 같아요 그러니까 어떤
한 분야에 너무 이렇게 집중을 하면
뭐 예를 들어서 빌딩 매매만 하면은이
시장이 만약에 좀 거래가 좀 줄었을
때 타격이 좀 굉장히 클 수 있거든요
그래서 좀 안정적으로 수익이 나오는
구조를 좀 많이 잘나야 되는 거
같습니다 아마 내년에도 좀 이런 좀
사업 다각화를 하려고 좀 많이 노력을
할 거고 좀 안정적으로 좀 이렇게
수익이 발생되는 그런 사업을 좀
키우려고 많이 하고 있습니다 그래서
올해 뭐 빌딩 거래량은 좀 많이
줄었지만 그래도 건설이나 뭐 빌딩
관리나 뭐 이런 쪽에서 조금 그나마
선방을 해 줘서 어 다행이었던 거
같습니다 그 저는 하고 빨리 이동을
해봐야 야 될 거 같아요 그래서
이따가 한 점심 시간 대쯤 다시
돌아오도록 하겠습니다들이 어 전체 다
매입하고 싶다고 하셔가지고 혹시
유튜브로 찍을 수 있냐고 물어 보셔
가지고 뭐 만약에 되면은 뭐 촬영도
괜찮을 것 같아 네네네 그리고 뭐지
저희 현수막 혹시 결정되 시야 그
아직 결정 안 났어 그거 근데 빨리
해야 되는데 그 현수 여기도 달 수
있어요 여기 있다가 이만하게 달아도
된다 그래가지고 진 예 허락
받았습니다 지금부터 달아도 돼가지고
아 진짜요 빨리 만들어야겠다 이거
그냥 지금 이제 임대 마치는 거죠
네네 잠금 전에도 그냥 붙여 된다
그래가지고 확인했습니다 알겠습니다
빨리 오늘 오늘
결정해야네습니다
하세요 제가 봤을 때는 이렇게 막
문구도 막 이렇게 많이 안 써도 될
거 같아요 빌딩은 bsn 건축 설계도
bsn 건설도 bsn 관리도 bsn
그 런게 심플하지 한게 낫지 않아요
그죠 엄청 크게 해가지고 전화번호
하면 될 거 같은데 한 수막 달게
되게 많아요 지금 공사하는 것도 다
달아야
되고음 오늘 오늘 넣던지 해야 될 거
같아요 목소리가 왜
이렇게 저녁 계약 있어 가지고 그것
때문에 얘기 나누고 있는 거 같습니다
거의 보통 계약할 때 한 한 여섯 명
일곱 명이 붙어서 그 계약 이슈라 뭐
계약서라 이런 거 다같 검토를
하거든요 약간 자랑이기 하지만
이때까지 창업 일회 중계 사고가 난
적이 단 한 번도 없어요 소송에
휘말리거나 이런 적도 단 한 번도
없고 영업 정지를 당한 적도 없고
매년 많은 건수에 계약을 하지만 뭐
지금까지 뭐 중계 사고라는 뭐 이런게
없었던 이유가 어 몇 명이 달라붙어
가지고 이슈가 있는지 뭐 이런 것들을
같이 살펴서 좀 없지 않나 저도 원래
중개법인 대표를 5년 동안 하다가 내
2년 전에 어 직원들 끼 다 이제
투표를 해가지고 제일 잘할 거 같은
사람한테 넘겨 주자라고 해서 대표를
지금 넘긴 상태고 그래서 아마 지금
좀 그것 때문에 제가 좀 외부
활동이라는 이런 거를 좀 그래도 잘할
수 있었던 거 같습니다 그래서 지금
중개 법인에는 제가 소속 공인중개사로
돼 있고 잠깐 보여 드릴 수 있으면
회사 1층에 중개사 자격증을 다
배치해 놨어요 bsn 아무래도
중개사가 대부분입니다 보통은
중개법인이 이제 보조원이 되게 많거든
어 우리 회사는 다 이제 중개사고
보시면 되실 정도로 그 정도로
중개사가 좀 많이 있습니다 제가 봤을
때는 전국에서 좀 제일 많지 않나
싶습니다네 여기 보면은 공인중개사
자격증을 다 붙여놨습니다 제 자격증이
여기
있네요
2009년도에났습니다 이제만으로
바뀌어 가지고 18살에 땄어요
보시면은 자랑스럽게 다 걸어놨습니다
그래서 좀이 중개업 시장도 좀 이렇게
바뀌었으면 좋겠어요 진짜 보조원이
중계하는게 아니라
중개사들이 좀 이렇게 중계하는 깨끗한
시장이 되었으면 좋겠습니다 고객분들이
와서도 깜짝 놀라시더라고요 자격증이
왜 이렇게 많냐고 그래서 일부러
달아놨습니다 제일 잘 보이는
곳에 저기
들어오면은 중요합니다 큰 자산이
들어가는 것만큼 정말 꼼꼼하게
체크해야 될 부분
많이 안 먹었네
이거 샤인
머스 목표 같은 거 그래서 저희
중개사님 뭐 하고 계신지 한번 불씨에
가서 한번 좀 보도록 하겠습니다 뭐
불씨 점검 이런 건 아니고 자주
갑니다
1 아마 불편하긴 할 거예요
제 점심 시간 딱 지나고 나서서 많이
있을지 모르겠 네 물이
열립니다가
올
식사하셨어요네 뭔가
어색한데 식사하셨어요
어 이거 계속 받아보고 있죠네 계속
받아보고 있습니다 그니까 저희도 이거
레터 같은 거 좀 보내려 그러거든요
어 좋은 거
같어 사랑 저희 분기마다 나오는
자료들 있잖아요 맞아 맞아 그 실데
방
기본 그냥 매주 이렇게 보내는 것도
괜찮아 유튜브 잘 하고 있어요데
영상을 성동 하나 찍고 좀
보내드렸 그 편집하시는 분 있어요
최근에 구했어요 구하느라 계속 못
올렸다 유튜브로 이렇게 전화온 적
있어요
했어 아 몇
분어
그 기 단 같은에 내부 물 내부라고
해서 리 뭐하겠어요 어 실거
확인하겠습니다 실 떤
[음악]
물거 잘
나와요
수고하세요 브이로그라는게 사실 뭐
특별한 건 없고 이게 뭐 제
모습입니다 뭐 보통 이제 회의나 미팅
좀 많이 하고 그리고 뭐 저번
달까지만 해도 강의가 되게
많았었거든요 요번 달은 조금 강의가
없기는 한데 아무튼 좀 강의도 위주로
좀 많이 하는 거 같고 그리고 또
그때그때 좀 다른 거 같아요네 그 또
뭐 계약이 있을 때는 또 되게 바쁘고
그리고 유튜브 촬영도 웬만하면 이제
일주일에 한두건 정도는 찍으려고 하고
있는데 그리고 요즘에는 좀 이런
새로운 사업 같은 거 뭐 그런 것도
좀 생각해 보고
있고음 CEO 좀 그런 생각들이 많은
거 같아요 뭐 앞으로 어떻게 해야
될지 잘돼도 고민 안 돼도 고민 약간
요런 거 같은데 너무 옛날
사람 앞서 제가 영상 찍은 것처럼 전
되게 일찍 퇴근합니다 웬만하면
가족들이랑 웬만하면 저녁 식사를 같이
먹으려고 좀 일찍 퇴근하는 편이고
대신 또 일찍 왔잖아요 업무는 최대한
좀 빨리 보고 어 빨리 퇴근하는
편입니다 그래서 이제 조금 어 미팅
하나를 하고 이제 퇴근할 예정인데
브로그를 뭐 일단 가볍게 찍긴 했는데
여러분들 어떠셨는지 되게 궁금합니다네
혹시 만약에 또 뭐 얘기들이 궁금하다
아니면은 예전 스토리들이 궁금하다
지금 사업에 대해서 좀 궁금하다 뭐
이런 거 좀 남겨 주시면은 제가 한번
그걸 주제로 한번 다시 또 영상을
찍어 보도록 하겠습니다 준비를 하고
미팅을 하러 가보겠습니다 브이로그
영상은 여기까지 하겠습니다 감사합니다